so this is dark souls 2 it's coming up
pretty soon the last game was the best
game of the generation yes you're right
in that Danny your massive fan I am
about what I find interesting about it i
cain't came at like back in I feel like
the late 2011 or was a 2012 it was two
thousand i'm at on consoles for 11 and
then was paec like the following summer
or something yeah so I feel like that
game has been building in popularity
since then rather than when it came out
it was this massive of it yeah it has it
has legs it has you know word of mouth
is very important to Dark Souls yeah and
well of course demon's souls I mean it
started with Diaz right and then and
then Dark Souls came as the not sequel
to demon souls so what do you think of
it is about the game that like has
actually like it made people talk about
it in this like well a lot of that I
think has to do with its atmosphere it's
very dark a lot of it has to do its dark
what it does yeah there are souls as
well but also it's it's about not
holding your hand it's not that people
think about dark souls as the challenge
in the difficulty yeah but that's not
really what it's about it's about giving
the player all the tools that he and he
or she needs to sort of discover you
know you discover on your own it's not
just about you know hey this is hard
it's about hey the game trusts me to
figure it out it doesn't like drop you
know a thousand years of war on me at
one day I'm Skyrim wat like Skyrim style
and you know lets me figure out what you
know what to do and how to do it and
that kind of thing so so talk to us
about what's go what's going on here is
this started again what they call an
opening cutscene okay but I'm gonna I'm
gonna skip past feel free but what's
what's really interesting about that
cutscene is that there's there's like
full-on you know facial animation
talking like I'm not used to that in
Dark Souls with a you know with people
close up faces like with actually seeing
and lips and things so people having
masks and texts coming up that was kind
of the one of the charming things about
dark souls was that it did feel super
like Japanese or like super like the
combat style I'm like the sort of rough
edges I kind of find charming somewhat
yeah I mean good on PC and stuff anyway
it is it was still rougher any edges it
has that Japanese element
sense of the animation priority kind of
combat that we associate with things
like monster hunter and and so on but
it's a lot it's a lot less the
animations aren't nearly so long that
you're like oh my god I have to sit here
for 10 minutes waiting for this
animation to finish before I can make my
next attack so this is the very
beginning i'm only allowed to show you
things that happen in the first hour
okay i'm not going to describe what any
of this means i'm not going to okay no
conscience no context whatsoever this is
how the game begins you you wake up in
this place called things betwixt okay is
I mean you can't talk for the next 20
minutes cuz that's gonna be super rad
can we ask you questions you can't help
with those bones I'm not telling you
anything about the bones so I've started
playing he be is so dark they were like
it that's it's dark solos kata another
name I started playing dark souls on PC
about a month ago and I found at the
start of the game I like Teddy didn't
basically didn't like tell you what was
happening once he did that first
tutorial level you were sort of thrown
into this almost like a hub world would
like loads of different directions to go
in is that similarly looking happening
morally now notice that when I started
unlike Demon Souls and Dark Souls I
didn't pick a class at the very
beginning we didn't choose things Yeah
right now I am just a blank slate okay
and so now here's another not dark souls
type thing which is an you know now we
have a cutscene that runs after we've
started the game yeah another a typical
thing usually those are reserved for
boss intros and that's it but now are
you going to get to pick your character
at this stage you'll see oh my lord
three wise old women I assume they're
wise they're old that doesn't
necessarily mean they're well they're
wearing red and they have candles and
stuff and they speak cryptically mm-hmm
and you aren't undead you are an undead
okay I'm allowed to say that because it
says so right there so it seems pretty
safe today proper along for a while
because maybe we should just skip it if
they do I will skip it they played a
prouder along I don't know I'm just
saying most ladies in my life
the beginning shot so this is where it's
like hey recall your name so let's just
call me danky kang we'll just call me
Kevin gavel right Kevin and yes I'm
absolutely sure my name Mighty Mite just
spelt it wrong which would a sock few
any questions by the way for mr. van or
by all means put them in the twitch shot
or in the game spot comments page and we
will pick them out i will skip that as
well but this is where I will be
choosing my class and my gift I reassure
you that my own body looks exactly like
that you're an Adonis so my main
character I'm playing a night ok I think
maybe that will do something that will
do will do swordsman stern you are quite
the swordsman KS at first gift you get
to cheat like this is very typical Dark
Souls petrified something um who knows
what that that's what I love about this
game is like headed they would just
throw out completely yes you wouldn't
have a clear what the hell it was the
bonfire ascetic is used to raise the
strength of nearby foes a seed of a tree
of giants you can't eat it who knows
what that does you don't know
necessarily i'm gonna go ahead and take
the life i bring it's like old demon
souls dark souls favor ok and then there
are other ways of course of customizing
customizing as well but i'm just gonna
go with that surprise it's such a good
approximation of my real-life body why
change it i got a question here from
chaotic bits is dark souls 2 essentially
based off of Dark Souls what I need to
complete dark souls in order to fully
enjoy Dark Souls no I mean you should
you should play dark souls you play
demon's souls because they're awesome
but it's not like you need those to
understand and of course now we come to
our very first bonfire this this is like
sort of the tutorial area you will see
notes here but notice that I can indeed
wash kill the tutorial if I prefer wait
so are then the notes obviously from the
previous games were sort of like some of
them were just parts of the game a
standard tutorial stuff some of them
were messages left by other players yep
is that so so we all feel still see
messages in this case that's a built-in
tutorial it's an actual like that the
shown is has actually tutorial hints on
it and now you'll see this later right
now I can't travel anywhere as you see
it's the only place I've unlocked but
you can actually now travel at will
between bonfire oh wow that you unlock
so pardon me while I do that so I don't
think up this item is there any ol and a
torch now that torch is very very
important although I don't I can't say
why ok or how great but I pan light the
torch and when doing so I now must have
it in my left hand because putting it
away will unlight the torch does this
like give you an extra life or something
is that what's happening who knows but
one of your goals is to light you can
lit torches as you go now of course you
see a foggy door in a Dark Soul game and
good times are behind it a good time
strip club there are lots of them here
so i will go through one of these to
give you an idea for now I'm just going
to get rid of oops get rid of the torch
now as you see I'm this class is 22
weapons enter the mists i'm going to
enter the mists the good news is there's
nothing that nasty behind it just
tutorial I want nasty i want to tell
what you kill something how to attack is
there any fundamental changes to the the
way the combat works and use these two
games I don't know if you just saw here
we go this is another player in another
in another world in my god of this world
get out of my game oops hello did ya is
there any any fundamental differences
between the combat because this event is
is a feeler ain't well supposedly it's a
new engine but there's nothing that
feels different about it okay this TV is
that dark what about the technical
performance of the game you find it that
it seems to me that the frame rates a
little bit better the frame rate does
seem to be but I haven't hit any I
haven't hit anything yet I think this is
okay to say that I haven't hit anything
yet as as irritating as blight town and
souls was that was one of the worst
technical things in modern video games
the frame rate in flight town in Dark
Souls this it it's hard for you to tell
at home but the TV is so dark I'm afraid
of movie cuz you can fall off the edge
so I'm Gaucho don't run I'm going on
rent like oh I I am going to go into if
I can the next area because there's a
moment that's super super memorable here
and I want to be able I want everybody
to sort of experience that moment
because you're used to Dark Souls being
this it's dark caverns yes awful places
it's I don't know what's going to happen
when I turn the corner because there are
gross things about alstead you come to
this moment as you emerge from the
tutorial area and you see this
okay that's pretty rad when that when I
first had that experience my heart just
blooms right there because I'm not used
to hope in Dark Souls Isis or suddenly
in Dark Souls 2 I i emerged and there's
this light and now i'm going to try to
this is the hub area and a lot of time
here it's called majulah and it's sort
of like in Demon's Souls how you would
go back to the Nexus yeah this is this
is essentially how dark souls 2 works is
you're going to come back to Missoula
but the first thing we're going to do is
a tune to this bonfire nice work and
i'll go ahead and rest again just
because i can now a few notes about
health you'll see i have a life gem down
there that's one of the health items and
that's actually a drop you will enemies
will drop those things but you also it
hang on here you also still have oh it's
not there yet you do also have flasks
Estus flasks like before but you only
get us you only get one to start with so
it seems like there's a lot of
familiarities with with dark souls 1 um
yes many in terms of the difficulty I
got a question you from Alex Clemens one
on Twitter a lot of folks wondering if
perhaps from software gonna maybe play
this towards you know a bit more popular
as do you think this feels as difficult
as the last game was I I'm not in a
position where okay okay talk about that
yet because because of the restrictions
we were going to be able to show the
game yeah but um gosh how can i how can
i drop any cryptic improv adoro matter i
can say we'll know soon when is it
revealed oh yeah next you'll know next
week at Tuesday morning 9am so this
young lady it's talking about drangleic
and that's the name of the world the
Dark Souls 2 takes place and it's not
the same world as dark souls is there
I've you again we probably have you seen
any connections between those two worlds
at all well yes in the city there are
vague narrative connect
and in terms of structure they are
connected III don't know all of the
official story behind how all of these
worlds connect but I never felt eyes do
they do exist in the same mental place
if nothing else I never felt I was
playing dark souls that there were like
well I guess maybe was a different
situation but there was much demon souls
references that I was missing out no no
a seminar here you can safely these
safely stand on their own and this is
the interesting part here because now
the game has put you into this place you
have these different spots that you can
go but you don't necessarily know
contraption does not move trap Shin does
not move how many hours did you put into
dark souls Oh over a hundred well yeah
that's pretty typical though yeah yeah
in Dark Souls 2 I am now level 56 okay
with my main character obviously not
with this character what's the coppa I I
don't know probably a thousand like
before lon I think it was a thousand
before I've never been at level 1000
we're getting some real deep questions
here on gamespot sajjad atheist preacher
wants to ask do spells use the stock if
you have two instances of the same spell
I do not know the answer to that okay
stackin spells yeah I haven't I'm not
playing as a spellcaster all right
although I do have my main character I
do have some some sorcery so but mainly
I'm just playing as a night with with
the sword and the shield was there any
stuff was only like fundamental things
you did not like about the previous game
that you wish did addressed in this one
there are those occasions where clipping
can get a little strange oh here's my
gorgeous when you come out to this this
spot turn to the right I'm going to see
that Vista see this show me that Vista
yeah
it's pretty look again I we're playing
this on the position she is 33 is on a
debug playstation 3 meaning it's a
developer yes station 3 but the game
will be exactly like this the reason you
know I'm hooked up online I will see
this should be here we go Gary all right
all right taking bets peter brian is
kevin gonna win this battle I had faith
of my man I'm gonna say yeah all right
i'm gonna go know are we betting is
there actual bit involved here no
there's no money in okay i have no money
i spent it all and taco bell in the
weekend I told you did so explain to
folks so maybe who often like played one
of these games before had the combat
works and what you're doing here to try
so the combat is is real time and some
of the tricks with the combat is to
understand you know how close you can
get to an enemy how you know how close
you know how long it takes to take to
make the attack and to really understand
and pay attention to what it is that
you're that your enemy is doing so that
you know how to take advantage of it it
sounds like normal video game calm yeah
right but in this case as you see one
attack can can make a huge difference
and with this class I'm not holding a
shield right now I just have my two
opening you know DOOL DOOL weapons
another part of it is the the endurance
aspect of stamina aspect so you see the
stamina bar below the health bar at the
top left and every time I do something
whether the take a block with the shield
whether I I dodge like that whether I
swing my weapon that uses up stamina and
stamina management is very very
important because otherwise you can get
yourself in really bad situations where
oh where you can't block where you can't
dodge or even attack it seems to be so
much more relevant in these games done a
lot of other games that have stamina
meters yes we're like I often feel and
perhaps a lot of RPGs there there just
to stop you from spamming
attacks where as in in these games it
seems to be like a fundamental almost as
important as your health bar see what's
interesting about these guys is when you
have a shield the easiest thing to do is
just stay really close to them and then
just lock the attack because their
attacks are highly blockable ah but can
you still use sort of janky physics to
knock guys off of yeah cliff that can
happen and it does that was my only way
of defeating those skeletons in the
start I came so i would just have to go
to the words of cliff and just try and
get them to hit me and then jump
slightly out of the way just the right
uphill path you're talking about you
have done to the graveyard and the
graveyard yeah killer bad decision
absolutely so I'm not used to dealing
with these guys with the Dodge so so but
yeah that that stuff is super super
important um and I don't think she did
she give me I think she gave me an Estus
flask but did I not fill it use it if
you want do it your way there we go yeah
I do have it now so I'm going to equip
the Estes blast so now I have that
available to me so of course oh well
what's going on there um you just don't
want to know it all right this question
the world of dark souls 2 is disgusting
horrible physically okay so now this
guy's not so bad either it's just more
of the same but another thing that's
important in Dark Souls is you have to
understand your surroundings because you
can and will fall hmm and so you come up
to a place where for example I know I'm
going to be dodging because i'm not
using a shield Oh Kevin I want you I
want to be dodging in this particular
area yes the answer is no this is this
your last death of the oh you want me
two guys just do it you don't know I
just want you to try and fight the dude
up there with is like okay I get what
you're saying if you're playing this
game in a week's time you should not do
it Kevin is about to do here yeah which
is fight this we'll see if I can manage
it you get him to fall off try that one
I'm gonna do that I believe in you Kevin
I know you don't I've never tried that
particular trick with these dudes I have
there is a trick in one area where I can
routinely get some dudes to fall off
all right you know what store yourself
up dad oh you want me to die on the
other gopher yeah why not all right too
good at this video again Kevin valor
word I want to see you Thomas I'm gonna
say the line let me at least kill him
I'm gonna show you one more thing and
then I will die all right are you having
together I killed them all right cool so
let's let's head down here all right and
you will see this is taking one of those
dudes on at once is all fine and dandy
but then what happens when you have
three of them and you soon find out and
that's that's what it comes down to is
manipulation it comes down to kiting
enemies into particular areas where
you're more comfortable fighting them
sometimes I can feel a little bit like a
little bit like a cheat like you're
exploiting the game but that's that's
how you survive exciting for coming oh
it's a sin to just you off yet it's not
dark souls without actual kidding you're
saying on oh and I'm being Kevin I'm
gonna activate and i'll show you another
cut but you see about you see a cool
thing happened like you see the yes see
that was pretty cool okay okay now now
did i murder yourself I'm gonna and I'm
gonna do it with the jump which I do it
lightly new woohoo onus life great and
there you go and just like video games
the main protagonist can kill people but
he can't swim thanks Obama